y antojó tierra en Cuba como huracán
categoría 3 llevando Vientos sostenidos
de hasta 205 kilómetros por hora dejando
cortes eléctricos y suspensión de la
mayoría del tráfico terrestre y marítimo
por las intensas lluvias y los poderosos
vientos al occidente de La Isla como
peligroso
estamos Casi ya se acostumbrados a estas
cosas bien se pone feo aquí el agua
llega hasta aquí hasta las rodillas
siempre eso cuando penetra lo que es el
sur para acá según reportes preliminares
se reportan daños materiales en las
provincias de Pinar del Río y Artemisa
la principal región tabaquera de Cuba en
la Habana capital del país se registran
lluvias moderadas e interrupciones
eléctricas intermitentes la estación
espacial internacional público imágenes
satelitales de Ian mientras este avión
caza Huracanes se adentró en el ojo del
ciclón mientras sigue su recorrido hacia
el estado de Florida donde se prevé que
toque tierra de miércoles a jueves
las autoridades pidieron a sus
habitantes prepararse antes un inminente
llegada
la gente debe estar preparada si se
encuentra en esta región y va a haber
una interrupción del suministro
eléctrico planifíquelo comprenda que eso
sucederá Incluso si la tormenta el ojo
de la tormenta no llega a su región
usted va a tener viento realmente
significativos
Caimán Con vientos en ráfaga de 120
kilómetros por hora sin reportar mayores
daños